you believe she said we were destroyed
no exactly the opposite we are
constructed we're constructed
okay family movie night guys oh whoa
what Will's getting a divorce so call
him we literally haven't spoken to each
other in years call him that's what
friends do
hey how are you really how are you how's
the bear business I'm actually the
brewmaster at my own bar now
congratulations you still got that uh
family of yours you want to see a photo
wow there they are cool
[Music]
what are you up to
so lunch no brunch no I don't have time
for this can't be friends with a girl
there's lots of famous men and women
friends Laura Dern and Sam Neal in
Jurassic Park
[Applause]
you're a friendship with Will
built for the
[Music]
midlife crisis there's a couple of
teenage girls your whole thing is so
weird and destructive
said we were destruction no we're we're
exactly the opposite we are constructed
I don't like feeling like the second
most important man in your life
it's embarrassing being a mess in front
of you and Will's a much bigger mess
than I am
for you to end up happy well I am happy
I've never been happier in my life
send me the invoice
break out of your box do a little nose
candy with us
did they actually pay back in the day
just like a mild horse tranquilizer it's
a horse
you can't blow it out it's already in
the brain
yeah
in my defense
I thought it was cocaine
and just though I'm clear that's your
defense
the defense rests
[Applause]
[Music]